on va commencer
installez vous dans votre fauteuil bien
gentil monsieur le guen bonjour bonjour
pour préparer ces entretiens j'ai petit
faiseur de gauche ensemble et je me suis
posé la question suivante est ce que
parfois vous vous sentez prisonniers du
big bazar
je rappelle simplement que le big bazar
ces cinq ans
monsieur le monde
j'ai 52 ans de métier donc ça ne fait
même pas 10%
heureusement que je suis jamais arrêtée
sur l'ubs elle a gelé même jamais réfuté
j'ai même jamais vu en fait chier avec
les big bazar c'est un bonheur
incroyable d'avoir un capital qui s'est
fait en quelques années
chaque chanson apporter c'est incroyable
quoi
oiseaux
ça
[Musique]
je suis curieux de savoir un nouveau
plus gros succès c'est la chanson fais
comme l'oiseau adaptations de chansons
brésiliennes
absolument comment est bien avez-vous su
que ce serait un succès heureusement
pour moi je ne savais pas je ne savais
pas que ça allait être un succès c'est
une chanson que j'avais il me manquait
une chanson sur le premier album du big
band à trois ans avant j'étais au brésil
et j'avais entendu du veau c'est à vous
aussi
ah bon
surtout que j'ai entendue chanter par
15000 personnes justes et en place et je
suis tombé dessus j'ai donné un pierre
delanoë qui lui ne connaît pas le
brésilien et il me fait fais comme
l'oiseau
je me mets je me suis toujours méfié de
l'oiseau avec pierre delanoë
il avait quelques mots comme ça qu'ils
étaient des mots clés oiseaux sortilèges
malm un formidable
chaque fois qu'un formidable vous pouvez
être sûr qu'il ya pire dans la vie était
pas loin
le message de fécamp oiseaux
c'est un message d'un mec qui perdu et
parce que parce qu'il n'y a pas d'amour
parce qu'il ya la guerre parce que m
et tout le monde entend ça tout le monde
entend c'est pas un message colossal
d'ailleurs chaque fois que un message
passe dans une chanson
il est en général simple il est exprimé
simplement en peu de mots faut se méfier
des mots dans les chansons vous êtes de
passage au québec parce qu'au mois de
mai vous allez faire des causeries
musicales
alors où trouvez-vous votre plaisir à
faire ces causeries musicales le plaisir
il vient il vient forcément avec un peu
d'âge un peu de kilométrage au compteur
parce que je prends un grand plaisir
maintenant à l'âge que j'ai c'est à dire
76 balles et a passé le témoin à faire
comprendre 7,6 à des jeunes générations
si cette serre tant que te gêne pas
prend le pas ce qu'il ya des règles non
dit dans nos métiers que personne
n'apprend et qu'on apprend sur le tas et
des règles des fois qu'ils font très
très très très mal
chaque échange
[Musique]
il ya 45 ans vous à m'interpréter chante
comme si tu devais mourir demain urnes
avait un peu plus tôt que vous avez 76
balle est ce que cette chanson
communication voilà signification le
poids de cette chanson je le traduis
simplement par le fait qu' elle est
toujours la dernière chanson et du
spectacle
de tous les spectacles que je fais c'est
à dire on part en ce kit est le seul
message que j'ai envie de lécher s'ils
chantent comme si tu aimerais demain
c'est à dire ne laisse pas passer une
seconde de la vie et dieu sait qu'elle
est il peut y avoir des parpaings que
que des fois il ya des mots mais il ya
des emmerdements qui vous tombe sur la
gueule et il faut et pourtant il faut
continuer de vénérer la vie c'est j'ai
pas envie de parler d'eux ni de visites
afin de la vie et la mort et c'est c'est
le gourmandise de la vie qui m'intéresse
c'est comment on la prend avec ses
emmerdes avec ses joies avec ses petits
bonheurs
arrêtons de chercher les grands bonheurs
et petits bonheurs successifs
ça fait toujours se finit par faire un
vrai bon cette rencontre était pour moi
un grand bonheur merci nous confie t il
ciao
les gens
[Musique]